foreign
to alcohol while we're on that topic is
if I drink something that doesn't taste
incredible I pour it out like I'm never
gonna tolerate a bad glass of wine ever
it's just not worth it let's just sit
with the alcohol for a second so what
are your personal rules for alcohol
consumption outside of the if it tastes
mediocre or shitty it gets poured out
which is a great rule but what are your
favorite types of alcohol how do you
personally navigate that well I'll start
with like kind of quantity I would
personally just say
there's going to be an insane reason to
have more than two drinks in a day
so it's somewhere between zero and two
and it's got to be a really good reason
to drink on more than three days a week
so in the back of my mind I'm keeping a
tally which is I really shouldn't be
having more than about seven drinks in a
week
and again seven drinks in one day is
very different than one drink a day for
seven days so it's the frequency and
it's the dose and that defines the
poison
the second thing is I really have to
make sure that that drinking is a good
three hours away from sleep
again when I say these things people say
Peter you must be a robot no I'm just
saying these are general principles
there are going to be times when I
violate that I think I posted something
on Instagram a little while ago which
was like the most rancid night of sleep
and I sleep data were comically bad and
the reason was we had friends over it
was very late we drank we ate you know I
basically went to bed you know by the
time they left at like 10 30 I went to
bed and we had just finished eating sort
of thing and not surprisingly my sleep
sucked the point I made in the post was
I'd do it again it was a fantastic night
our friends and the four of us hadn't
had dinner together in a long time so
you just have to be very thoughtful and
deliberate about the choices and
trade-offs that you make as far as the
type of alcohol
you know I think people I think love to
this isn't again an example of something
I think we tend to over index to oh you
know I drink a lot but let me tell you
it's just vodka and tequila so it's got
to be good for me right it's like no
alcohol is alcohol right so I love
tequila I love Mezcal I love
really good wine and I love really dark
Belgian beer I'm not deluded to think
that any of those are healthy and I know
that there are some people who have you
know a horrible reaction to certain
types of alcohol well I would put that
in the same categories people who have a
horrible reaction to certain types of
foods don't consume them
but I think mostly where I focused him
is on how much am I going to drink
how close is it going to be to bed and
What's the total tally per week and
never exceed a certain tally in a given
day